danielle why don't you give us an update
on what's going on with the economy
today
well uh
let's um
let's bring up the chart let's start off
today by bringing up the chart
because believe it or not what's going
on with the economy has a lot to do with
how much money the government is giving
people and people don't have a good
appreciation for that we're actually
starting to see shipping rates turn
and this is a global phenomena we're
starting to see inventories build this
is a global phenomena so the supply
chain disruption that we've been talking
about for the last 18 months it's
starting to dissipate and companies have
gone from
just in time to just in case so you
don't want to build up stockpiles by the
way that's not good business practices
and yet so many companies are
on the fiscal front though if you look
at what
beef inflation was damn near 25
year-over-year forget the 6.8
forget that but poultry was up 14
year-over-year i mean we're talking
about
monumental moves in the most essential
prices
we know housing prices are through the
roof however there's a reason there's a
reason that we're seeing inflation to
the extent that we are and it has
everything to do with fiscal policy run
amok so this is
the
the supplemental nutrition
assistance program
and this it used to be called food
stamps yep
on the day that biden
said had to walk back and say
i meant what i said august 6 16 about
afghanistan
he had a new york headlines hit right
then and there new york times headline
hit that said snap benefits to increase
32 percent and the biggest increase in
the history of the program so he signed
an executive order in january and he
said let's revisit the food pyramid and
see how much money we really need to
give families and by the way
in
oh
in
right right before the pandemic we were
kind of in the hundred and ninety dollar
range-ish 125 range this is per person
can you explain to the average person
what this is this is the average benefit
that an american receiving what we used
to call food stamps gets deposited to a
debit card on a monthly basis okay so
this is this is this is a food stamps
being in a way given away to the average
person right and in in in august when he
was when the international community was
enraged because of how badly afghanistan
had gone yep
the executive order all of a sudden the
report was ready to be rolled out that
same day that said we're going to give
people 32 more 32 so they buried it
essentially
october the first
data are not available
but this is this is an extrapolation if
you will because we only have data
through september but if you extrapolate
what the average
u.s household was getting
give or
four
take
dollars
you bump it up five hundred and seventy
dollars
per household that's it that's got like
two kids
per household add that to the average of
550 that 61 of the 73 million children
in america are getting the child tax
credit
90 percent of u.s households with
children are getting cash from the
government
yesterday was the last payment
and you add these two up 90 90
in 2019 there were 73 it's hard to
believe in 2019 there were 73 million
children in america we know that since
then the birth rate has declined so that
73 number is probably high and
immigration has crashed so but
as of as of december the 15th the last
cash payment that we know is going to
occur without build back bigger
as of december 15th the average u.s
household was getting 550 in cash 90
61 million of the 73 million children in
america families who do not need the
money period end
in addition to that the cares act
greatly expanded the percentage of
americans who are eligible for
assistance with with buying food
so on october the 1st we don't have the
data yet the benefits went up by 32
again
you hear these anecdotes if you're if
you're joe q household in america and
you're getting 1100 in cash at a minimum
a month and you your spouse can stay
home
which means you don't have to pay for
child care are you ever going back into
the workforce
so probably probably not for core jobs
under fifty thousand a year exactly
because it does make economic sense and
that's the line they've done the math so
they're giving people so much money that
that the fraud is rampant
if you're joe q with five kids
and you're getting
1500 a month times two
if you're joking what do you do with all
this money on a debit card to buy food
right when you don't wanna buy that much
food
you sell it to your sure you sell it to
your liquid uncle for 50 cents on the
dollar you got eight thousand dollars
sitting on this debit card they're like
what the hell am i gonna do with eight
thousand dollars i don't want food i
want other things but is this stopping
no this is not stopping that's why whip
out the chart
there's some emergency measures in there
that are going to decrease so what
you're saying is
to divert from the afghanistan
i'm just i'm just saying that it was a
coincidence that it happened to roll out
on the same exact day right that he had
to he had to say i stand by myself
august 16th got it got it so it's one of
those coincidences like dropping a new
store at four o'clock on friday and the
other tricks that our government does to
kind of divert the distraction so we
could debate the attraction but on that
day they raised it and it was not
temporary it's permanent and so you have
people that are getting a tax credit
simply because you check the box that's
how you fill out your taxes and the tax
software does it automatically and then
you that's the half you're talking about
and the other half is these debit cards
that are out there for the other half of
them because 90 american households
don't have one of these debit cards this
is not ninety percent of the child tax
credit so you're talking ninety percent
of you are getting and then tax credit
that you're that your
your tax guys quicken software
automatically puts on because it's part
of the regulation and then the other
half is getting these cards and these
cards are now up to this to the point
that there's a secondary redis
redistribution model where people are
monetizing it and selling it to you and
i'm not saying that this is the norm but
i'm just i was in austin for the for
down the middle austin series last week
and we're i mean to hear the anecdotes
of somebody with eight ten thousand
dollars built on on a debit card you
sell it to your uncle who's liquid
your uncle gives you 50 cents on the
dollar so you've got cash to buy
whatever you want
all the all the bad goodies in the world
all the good goodies in the world what
does your uncle do are those debit cards
only they're anonymous they're anonymous
okay they're interchangeable so what is
your opinion there's not a name on there
no you just use it at use almost like a
gift card when you go to check out a
kroger you can buy a cold sandwich but
not a hot sandwich
and you can't buy booze and you can't
buy cigarettes you can't buy anything
that's bad for you right you only bought
standard food at right there at the
little checkout at kroger you would just
use it and they have no clue that you're
using so basically a card that's
approved gentlemen i have a quick
question before we before we jump in if
you're the uncle who just paid paid 50
cents on the dollar for this card
what's for dinner
is it is it ground beef
or is it waiku
whatever they're hungry for exactly
because they've just paid 50 cents on a
dollar for cash
why is why is beef inflation up 22 year
over year
why is a pound of bacon 9.99 but but
here's here's what happens with this
this is when you get destroyed in
midterms you know destroyed yeah
destroyed so the point the point is
there's cause and effect the great thing
about the system is there's cause and
effect you can do all of this free stuff
thinking it's going to work and then you
realize the math doesn't make any sense
and then you get destroyed and then
everybody says it was your fault and
then they gradually distanced themselves
from you because god forbid if a person
has seen that say biden camp and you're
a congressman trying to run again
you're like if you're part of his camp
you're not going to get re-elected you
notice a lot of people are not getting
around him today they're trying to stay
away from ncnn yesterday i don't know if
you guys saw cnn yesterday they made a
uh
story they talked about the fact that
who are some potential candidates to
replace biden right they're already
talking about they were taking a huge
deal out of that
they were not they weren't that was like
their talking thing of the day and did
you hear what one person came out and
said yesterday that said if it's going
to be a consequential event if this
person gets reelected you know who that
legendary person was that said this the
sweetest human being in the world the
most beloved person in america who is
more ambitious to want to be a president
than anybody else we have currently in
america that didn't get there but
newsweek did a special magazine on this
individual saying madam president do you
know who that person is
hillary clinton yeah exactly imagine if
hillary runs again in 2023 2020
so anyway so the point is you can do all
this stuff all you want but you're not
going to do well right and you're going
to get crushing midterms so keep doing
it yeah and you know danielle the key
word that you threw out there was fraud
because this thing is just ripe for
fraud you know
you game the system last fall so when i
was not just ripe the fruit's being
picked you're correct
so when i was going back and forth from
dallas to l.a last last year the final
four months of the year i was going back
and forth every single week every single
week the planes were full right and this
is when travel was shut down and i could
not figure it out i mean why are the
planes full coming back from dallas to
l.a you can't go anywhere the city's
shut down there's nothing to do finally
this really smart guy informed me what
was going on and he was an uber driver
the la the massive level of fraud that
was going on with the handouts last year
on the debit cards people would fly in
that have never been on a plane before
by the way a lot of these people have
never flown anywhere they come to la
uber drivers pick them up and drive them
from atm to atm they withdraw 300 at a
time on these fraudulent cards and then
they rent big houses in the hollywood
hills and throw these huge parties they
rent luxury cars for two to three
thousand dollars a day and that's what
was going on for four months billions
and billions and billions of dollars in
fraud with that handout program last
year all right by the way a few people
got arrested and they went to jail for
it i mean there's major stories out
there i'm going to pose a question to
tom because he got one step in front of
me because you were you were going right
where i was going because patrick
started up by saying where is the us
it's trouble when you compliment time no
no no because it's over especially at
the beginning of the show we're done
he knows what's happening this is my
sister from another mother we're
thinking the same way he knows what
happens on
okay so if you're joe q i've been
collecting the child tax credit in cash
do you still anticipate that you're
going to get your big tax refund on
january the 31st when you go to h r
block or wherever you go to
electronically file your taxes are you
still planning on getting that tax
refund like in general or that day no
just in general the middle class and the
slightly upper middle class that's using
hr block they still think that's coming
so they still think the income tax
refund absolutely but the child tax
credit has been paid out in cash
post facto past tense
so we're talking about whoopsie
and ann biden wants to start paying back
student loans on february the first
right at the same time that people are
not getting their income tax refunds
that they were thinking that they were
gonna get to pay off their credit card
debt from christmas
oh it's just going to be too fire up the
printing presses more money no it's just
that the republicans don't even have to
they don't have to hire an advertising
agency for the for the primary season
patrick is correct you can just sit back
and just and say 61.
well and then you couple all that with a
crime right and then it's a toxic you're
absolutely right well pat made a point a
minute ago he says hey you can keep
doing this for free this what they have
done on fiscal policy during this
reaction to covet and they have pushed
the free pendulum all the way over here
it's a combination of free and printing
money and they push it over here all of
a sudden that pendulum is going to be
too heavy and it swings back the other
way it has to
it has to and they can spin it all they
want and saki can say whatever she wants
from the podium and the average person
is telling you my milk is now six bucks
a gallon the average person is telling
you my gas is expensive and those are
the people that are going to the polls
so you can spin it any way you want but
the charts are speaking truth and pat's
you're absolutely right it's coming so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you